I joined this party when I was 17 and
over the last 22 years through all the
ups and downs Liberal Democrats have
felt like a family to me
conferences campaign by elections from
Brent to Bracken twelve years as an MP
three years as a minister losing my seat
winning it back again and now I'm now
standing here as your leader ready for
the fight of our lives you have put your
trust in me not only to lead our party
but also to lead and grow the bigger
open liberal movements that our country
so desperately needs there who think
liberalism has had its day that it is
somehow obsolete but when I think of all
the amazing people I met on the campaign
trail
and when I look around this room I can
feel the energy the passion and the
determination to fight for our values
liberalism is alive and thriving
[Applause]
in the face of nationalism populism the
catastrophe of brexit the two old
parties have failed our party have been
clear on break that from day one we
believe the UK's best future is as
members of the European Union and that's
why as you're a leader I will do
whatever it takes to stop pregnant
[Applause]
it's the Liberal Democrats who can lead
the renewal our country needs together
we can build a better future so thank
you for joining me whether you are a
lifelong Lib Dem or you are joining us
for the first time today I couldn't have
won this race without the support and
love of Duncan and my mum or without the
pure joy that Andrew and Gabriel bring
me
okay not a day went by on the campaign
that I didn't think about my dad he
would have loved today I want to I want
to thank my incredible campaign team and
the many many volunteers who have helped
us over the last few weeks and months
and I want to thank my team in
Westminster and in eastern Bart ensure
this is your victory - it simply
wouldn't have been possible without all
of you we all know that running
elections is a challenging business so
thank you to the returning officer and
the HQ staff who helped this election
run smoothly not least while fighting to
parliamentary by-elections and I
especially want to thank ed
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
campaigns are hard constant scrutiny
constant pressure endless travel endless
hustings so much time away from loved
ones I know ed and I have both felt this
as we have toured the country from
Aberdeen to Plymouth and seemingly
everywhere in between and have carried
himself with grace throughout and never
lost his passion nor his sense of humor
I have a huge amount of respect for Edie
which is only grown through this
campaign he was an exceptional minister
in government and his environmental
record is second to none we have worked
together for years and we agree on most
things it turns out which I admit didn't
always make for the most exciting
contest I'm proud to call aired a friend
and that we have both won clean
campaigns focusing on the issues that
really matter
Eadie is a huge talent for our party and
I can assure you he will be absolutely
essential to our tea
[Laughter]
when I decided to stand for the
leadership I did though
so thinking the challenge facing our
party would be a very different one we
were stubbornly all around 8% in the
polls
new parties were springing up courting
Lib Dem votes it seemed that the first
task I would face as leader would be to
ensure our very survival but what a
turnaround our best set of local
elections ever more any P's than ever
before opinion polls that put ours in
first or second place Liberal Democrats
are winning again
and for that I pay tribute to my two
most immediate predecessors Tim for
taking that brave decision in the wake
of the referendum to say unequivocally
that we are the party of romaine and
Vince for your leadership that has
brought about our revival for being a
voice of reason in unreasonable times
Vince you have served our party and our
country with distinction for decades
from your sage warnings before the
financial crash to your work rebuilding
our economy as business secretary you
have been a constant source of wisdom
and in a leader of our party you have
led a transformation in our fortunes
thank you so much
[Laughter]
I know that I have some pretty big shoes
to fill
whether that's Vince's ballroom shoes or
Ming Campbell's Olympic running spikes
or Nick Clegg who put the country first
at a time of national crisis and showed
that Liberal Democrats can make a real
difference when we take power and put
our principles into practice our Paddy
Ashdown who took us from an asterisk in
the opinion polls to a credible
political force and Charles Kennedy who
was shouted down in Parliament for his
principled opposition to the Iraq war
and whose sincerity endeared him to
millions and how much we all miss paddy
and Charles today